people from Louisiana to Indiana are
dealing with major flooding this morning
heavy rain and melting snow caused
rivers to rise to record highs flooding
homes and businesses more rain is
expected to start tonight flood watches
and warnings are in effect all the way
from Texas to the Great Lakes
David beg no is in downtown Louisville
where the flooding is the worst the city
has seen in two decades David good
morning hey Nora good morning amid a
lovely sunrise here in Louisville
Kentucky the waters receding here Aloma
along the Ohio River that's the banner
headline everybody here is more than
happy to hear February ended up being
the wettest month ever they got about 10
inches of rain in just five days and
here's what it did so the water started
to fall that's the Ohio River right
there the river rose and as it did the
river swollen right so you got the river
boats that's where they belong but the
water should essentially stop there but
it started to move into the city
downtown you've got parking garages here
where vehicles are underwater and look
how close the water is to the street
signs it's only about 4 to 5 feet under
the traffic lights through downtown
Louisville now the Ohio River has caused
problems as well in Aurora Indiana where
the water was so high on Monday it
reached the bottom of the football field
goals and even the scoreboards more than
70 rivers across the u.s. are
experiencing moderate to major flooding
right now looking ahead rain is expected
in Arkansas and Mississippi tonight and
even tomorrow and that could cause some
flash flooding Gale back here in
Louisville get this so they got about 40
billion gallons of rain that fell 40
billion gallons of water that fell in
the city of Louisville over the last
five days that's about the same amount
of water that the city produces in 10
years
got it David your pictures really tell
the story there thank you very much